rebecca bonsoir bonsoir alors on part
avec brigitte boisjoli ce soir brigitte
boisjoli ex star académicienne deuxième
album est avec celui ci sans regret est
elle vraiment les d'études faire plaisir
c'est une affirmation de soi parce
qu'elle fait ce qu'elle aime est ce que
les coupes depuis qu'il est petit c'est
à dire l'assaut du r'n'b et du montant
en français on écoute sur je me le sort
conforté par là
je m'en serais
cinéma comme le dit si tu aurais dû à l
ça fait vraiment penser à une chanson de
back to black c'est ce qu'ils ont dit
que ça fait penser à plusieurs choses
dont cette chanson de dr dre rappeur de
la côte ouest avec une chanson qui date
de 2001 watts de des prix est juste en
vérité de ce gang
alors on s'entendait ici c'est une
coïncidence entre médor curé lui à
échantillonner de charles aznavour
pas ce que tu crois que tu es ma fleur
donc une chanson à ce niveau parce que
tu crois que ça date de 1969 et
longtemps et c'était juste j'accuse pas
du tout brigitte boisjoli et d'avoir
copié mais je trouve ça intéressant de
voir qu'il ya des belle coïncidence et
que tout a déjà été fait finalement son
album est heureux c'est un album
diablement efficace elle a demandé à
tous les gens in en ce moment alex
nevsky yann perreau amylie dumas betty
bonifassi d'y écrire des chansons le
seul bémol c'est qu'elle a une manière
de chanter qui rappelle céline dion
parfois il ya des petits tics des fois
je vous parle ce truc des fois ça peut
déranger des fois non
si tout d'un coup tu m'as dit que tu as
changé l'amour pensée magique au 7e trou
dans lequel je n'ai pas berner
voilà pour brigitte boisjoli oui
maintenant par l'eau nous dit-il ni
hautaine au tennis et un écossais
son père d origine toscane mais
moi je suis très en retard je dois
l'avouer parce que sixième album paolo
nutini qui le 27 ans seulement et amy
winehouse ils le veulent ce temps il le
fait il fait la musique et une voix et
une viande donc lui ce qu'il fait c'est
du boulot à ixxo ça va vous faire penser
à joe cocker afin de morzine jay kay
vraiment le muscle et r'n'b funk j'ai
adoré chichis
j'aime aussi
aulas
ma a
fait
carlo n'utilisant à venir caustique
troisième à y résister dès la première
écoute on va se jeter là dessus je le
savais mais casser déjà tous ces jaloux
merci beauchamp